much indeed for speaking to us today why
is this course they close to your heart
it just always has been since since I
was very young
growing up in Hereford I'd see homeless
people and it would always stay with me
and always really affect me and I used
to you know ask my parents why this
person was living on the street and and
then it you know when I moved to London
I saw more and more and it and it wasn't
my eyes deceiving me it was it was
genuinely more and more people on the
streets and it has been on the rise
every year and as soon as I was in a
position where I could really do
something and make a difference that's
what I did and I've been I've been
putting on a show every year which we
have at Christmastime because you know
that's the time where I think people
feel the most vulnerable and lonely I
think something that always strikes me
whenever I speak to people who are rough
sleepers or homeless it's just how easy
it is for people to find themselves in
that situation it can just be one stroke
of bad luck one missed paycheck what are
the sort of stories they exactly I've
heard so many stories now at this point
I think the most important thing that
I've done over the years in volunteering
is talking to people and listening to
people's stories and there's a real
misconception about homelessness and
still a big stigma surrounding it that
people have brought it on themselves
which is absolutely not true you know
it's only a couple of mortgage payments
or a broken down marriage - you know if
your life to completely turn around for
the worse and you know it just it just
shows it really can happen - to any of
us and it's not just what people assume
which is that people have ended up in
that situation through their own you
know thing so I think listening to
people it has been really really
important yeah absolutely and of course
rough sleeping is one thing but there
are also thousands of families in in
temporary accommodation having lost
their homes what would you like to see
done to help these people yeah there's a
thing called the hidden homelessness
which is is not necessarily the people
excuse me you see on the street but
young people who have had to leave their
home for various reasons may be getting
into fights and arguments with their
family over things and you know they
they might end up on buses through the
night or trains back and forth or sort
of couchsurfing their friends houses and
I think what I'd love to see is is first
of all more support especially with
things like mental health which is kind
of on the rise and and thankfully more
and more people are talking but I think
still more needs to be done and secondly
on a long-term basis there needs to be
more affordable housing and better
checks on on people who rent houses
because I think I think it's got to a
point where people are being sort of
forcibly removed from rented housing you
know with with very short notice and
that's actually one of the big reasons
why people end up on the on the street
very quickly yeah of course and I think
at this time of year as well with the
weather the winter it really does bring
it to the fore a kind gesture can go a
long way can't it what would be your
message to people if they want to do
something to help
I yeah I think that honestly the
interaction is such an important thing
if you see somebody on the street that's
cold you know if you felt any anything
you can offer them whether it you know
be an umbrella or a blanket or a coat
but also you know just that exchange and
and and taking the time to stop and talk
to someone ask their name you know
sometimes they might not want to talk
but if they do want to talk you know do
do that obviously you know change and
food does help too but I honestly think
just taking the time and showing that
you've noticed them so many people get
ignored and and you know often them I've
seen videos lately which is which is an
absolute disgrace where people can get
on late nights out on people are drunk
and walking past homeless people they
can get abused and taunted and I think
that's an absolute disgrace and I think
that we just have to be more conscious
of that person being another human being
like yourself and you know and I just
want more people to to help each other
and be more compassionate and it and if
I can sort of try and you know teach my
fans that and younger people that then I
think it could be a nicer place
absolutely and it's not just about
offering homeless people a safe
environment it's about offering them a
way of climbing out of that situation
isn't it yeah once you once you become
homeless you can lose everything very
quickly you can lose your family your
friends you know your your the social
sort of network and you know you can
lose your confidence and it's it's a
it's a really really terrifying thing to
find yourself that lonely and without
anyone around you and so you know crisis
is so good
helping people at this time of year you
know short term people coming in and
we've got blankets and showers and food
and you know tea and and so there's that
but yeah god I kind of have so I had a
complete blank because I've got
distracted but don't worry
yeah I know sorry it's because I was
looking into the canteen and got
completely distracted oops I'm sorry
what was the question
just what more can people do I mean
obviously you you are doing some great
work with crisis and raising awareness
here if people want to also help what
can they do do you need more donations
for instance yep don't donations help
volunteering you can apply to volunteer
maybe not for this year but definitely
for next year and I think just just
being conscious and just knowing that
it's a problem knowing that it's a
problem on the rise and and you know and
and spreading that awareness and talking
about it and I think sometimes you know
it's something that a problem that
people kind of have to ignore because
it's it's so you know it's so horrible
to see as they're sad to see but really
it does need
come from the top from the government
and there needs to be more of a
political force